♪
>> Bret: BREAKING TONIGHT,
SENATORS ARE ON BREAK AFTER
VOTING 51 TO 49 NOT TO GO
FORWARD WITH WITNESSES.
NOW WE DON’T KNOW THE WAY
FORWARD FROM HERE.
LET’S TALK ABOUT IT WITH
MINNESOTA DEMOCRAT SENATOR
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE AMY
KLOBUCHAR.
SENATOR, THANKS FOR THE
TIME.
>> THANKS, BRET.
IT’S GREAT TO BE ON AGAIN.
>> Bret: I WANT YOU TO GET
TO REACT FIRST TO THE
WITNESS VOTE AND WHAT YOU
THINK IS HAPPENING MOVING
FORWARD.
>> I REALLY THOUGHT WE
SHOULD HAVE WITNESSES AND
YOU COULD SEE MITT ROMNEY
HAS BEEN OUTSPOKEN ABOUT
THIS FOR QUITE AWHILE.  I
THINK THE REASON IS.
THIS.
THE TRUTH IS GOING TO COME
OUT.
AND PEOPLE COULD VOTE THE
WAY THEY WANT ON
IMPEACHMENT.
I GET THAT PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO HAVE DIFFERENT OPINIONS.
BUT I REALLY FELT THAT IT
WAS IMPORTANT TO HAVE THE
WITNESSES BECAUSE WE HAVE
ALWAYS HAD WITNESSES IN
THESE TRIALS.
AND 70% OF THE PUBLIC WANT
TO SEE WITNESSES.
AND I REALLY BELIEVED WITH
THE BOLTON REVELATIONS THAT
HAVE COME OUT.
IT’S NOT GOING IT BE FIVE
YEARS FROM NOW THAT WE KNOW
WHAT HAPPENED IN THOSE
ROOMS.
IT’S GOING TO BE PROBABLY
FIVE DAYS FROM NOW OR FIVE
WEEKS FROM NOW.
AND I THINK IT IS BETTER TO
GET TESTIMONY UNDER OATH AND
THEN PEOPLE CAN MAKE
DECISIONS.
>> Bret: WE’RE REPORTING AT
THIS HOUR THAT DEMOCRATIC
AMENDMENTS TONIGHT INCLUDE
NO WEEKEND SESSION.
MONDAY, TUESDAY, COMMENTS ON
THE FLOOR AND THEN WEDNESDAY
AFTERNOON A FINAL VOTE.
ARE YOU OKAY WITH THAT?
>> WE HAVE BEEN PUSHING FOR
WITNESSES.
AND I WOULD ASSUME SOME OF
THE AMENDMENTS, THERE HAS
BEEN SOME DISCUSSION SINCE
THIS WENT DOWN NOW ON THAT
CLOSE 51-49 VOTE.
WHAT KIND OF AMENDMENTS TO
EXTEND THE TIMETABLE TO GET
SPECIFIC WITNESSES.
TO GET SPECIFIC DOCUMENTS.
SO THAT’S GOING TO BE THE
DISCUSSIONS.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO DO
WHATEVER IT TAKES TO GET A
FAIR TRIAL FOR THE PEOPLE OF
AMERICA.
AND WE’RE JUST AWAITING WORD
ON WHAT WE WORK OUT HERE.
>> Bret: BUT YOU DON’T HAVE
THE VOTES, SENATOR, SO GO
THROUGH THOSE PROCESSES AS
YOU ARE TRYING TO GET TO
IOWA AND OTHER PEOPLE ARE AS
WELL.
WHY GO THROUGH THAT IF YOU
DON’T KNOW YOU HAVE THE
VOTES IT?
>> CAN’T JUST BE MY
MOTIVATING FORCE.
I HAVE GOT TO BET THAT THE
PEOPLE IN IOWA UNDERSTAND
WHAT I’M DOING MY JOB.
I’M IN THE ARENA.
YOU KNOW, OTHER PEOPLE CAN
SAY I DON’T WANT TO LOOK AT
WHAT IS GOING ON THERE.
I HAVE GOT TO DO MY JOB AND
DOING.
>> Bret: CHAD PERSIAN PERGRAM HA
BEEN.
THE BATTERIES ARE AND WE
HAVE AMY KLOBUCHAR BACK.
QUOTED BY THE HOUSE
MANAGERS, THE DEMOCRATS.
HE SAID THIS IS WHY I TOLD
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE THAT
IT WAS A MONUMENTAL MISTAKE
TO RUSH THE IMPEACHMENT VOTE
ON INCOMPLETE RECORD AND
HAND OVER THEIR CASE TO THE
OTHER HOUSE AS THE OPPOSING
AND THE OPPOSING PARTY.
THIS WILL GO DOWN AS A
BLUNDER OF HISTORIC MEASURE
BY THE HOUSE LEADERSHIP.
YOUR REACTION TO THAT?
>> YEAH.
I JUST DON’T AGREE.
BECAUSE WE HAVE ALREADY SEEN
IN THE DON MCGAHN COURT CASE
THAT THE -- THEY KEEP
APPEALING, THE WHITE HOUSE,
ABOUT NOT PRODUCING THESE
WITNESSES AND THEY KNOW VERY
WELL THAT THEY CAN PUT ALL
THE PRESIDENT’S MEN, EVEN A
FEW OF THEM, UP TO TESTIFY
JUST LIKE THEY HAVE DONE IN
PAST IMPEACHMENT HEARINGS.
SO, I DON’T BUY THAT.
I THINK THEY JUST DON’T WANT
THOSE WITNESSES TO COME
FORWARD AND, AGAIN,
EVENTUALLY, THE TRUTH IS
GOING TO COME OUT.
AND THE OTHER THING I WOULD
SAY ABOUT IT IS EVERY DAY
THAT GOES BY, YOU NOW HAVE
GENERAL KELLY, PRESIDENT
TRUMP’S FORMER CHIEF OF
STAFF, SAYING THE JOB IS
HALF DONE.
THAT THERE SHOULD BE
WITNESSES.
YOU HAVE A NUMBER OF OTHER
PEOPLE, INCLUDING, OF
COURSE, MR. BOLTON AND JOHN
WARNER, THE FORMER SENATOR
FROM VIRGINIA WHO HAVE COME
FORWARD.
THESE ARE REPUBLICANS.
AND SAID THAT YOU SHOULD
HAVE A THOROUGH TRIAL WITH
WITNESSES.
SO, I JUST VIEW IT AS A
CONSISTENT EFFORT TO STOP
THESE WITNESSES FROM
TESTIFYING.
>> Bret: LET’S TALK ABOUT
IOWA.
HOW MUCH DO PEOPLE WHEN YOU
ARE ON THE GROUND ASK YOU
ABOUT IMPEACHMENT?
>> THEY DO SOME, ESPECIALLY
WHEN THINGS ARE GOING ON
LIKE THIS HEARING.
BUT, A LOT OF THEM ARE STILL
FOCUSED ON HEALTHCARE AND
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS, ON COST
OF COLLEGE.
BUT I DO THINK THIS
ELECTION, ESPECIALLY FOR
MODERATE REPUBLICANS AND
INDEPENDENTS IS MORE THAN
JUST AN ECONOMIC CHECK.
I TELL THEM ALL THE TIME,
ESPECIALLY PEOPLE SHOWING UP
AT MY EVENTS THAT MAY HAVE
VOTED FOR THE PRESIDENT OR
MAY HAVE STAYED HOME, I TELL
THEM, LOOK, YOU MAY NOT
AGREE WITH EVERYTHING THAT
IS SAID ON THE DEBATE STAGE.
I DON’T AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING ON THE DEBATE
STAGE, BUT THIS ELECTION IS
GOING TO BE A DECENCY CHECK
AND A PATRIOTISM CHECK.
AND THEY, MANY OF THEM,
BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD HAVE
A PRESIDENT THAT ISN’T
PUTTING HIS PRIVATE
INTERESTS IN FRONT OF THE
INTERESTS OF THIS COUNTRY.
AND THAT’S WHY THEY ARE
SHOWING UP AT MY EVENTS.
>> Bret: ARE YOU BETTER
POSITIONED AGAINST DONALD
TRUMP THAN JOE BIDEN.
DO YOU THINK THIS
IMPEACHMENT HEARING HAS HURT
JOE BIDEN AND HIS ABILITY TO
GO HEAD TO HEAD WITH DONALD
TRUMP?
>> I’M GOING TO LET THE
PUNDITS DECIDE ALL OF THAT.
I HAVE A LOT OF RESPECT FOR
THE VICE PRESIDENT.
BUT I KNOW THIS ABOUT ME.
AND THAT IS THAT I AM
SOMEONE THAT’S FROM THE
MIDWEST.
IT’S NOT FLYOVER COUNTRY TO
ME.
I’M ONE OF TWO CANDIDATES
THAT ARE FROM THE MIDWEST.
I’M ALSO SOMEONE IN ANOTHER
GENERATION.
AND I’M SOMEWHERE IN BETWEEN
THE AGE OF MAYOR PETE AND
THE VICE PRESIDENT.
I WOULD SAY THAT 59, MY AGE,
IS THE NEW 38.
AND I THINK ALL OF THAT IS A
GOOD THING TO HAVE A FRESH
FACE, TO HAVE SOMEONE THAT
IS NEW REPRESENTING OUR
PARTY AT THE TOP OF THE
TICKET.
>> Bret: THERE IS ONE POLL
JUST OUT THAT HAS YOU NOW IN
THIRD IN IOWA.
THE AVERAGE OF POLLS
NATIONALLY IN IOWA AND NEW
HAMPSHIRE HAS YOU, YOU KNOW,
IN FOURTH, FIFTH IN IOWA,
NEW HAMPSHIRE, WHERE DO YOU
SEE IT ON THE GROUND AND
WHERE DO YOU HAVE TO FINISH
IN IOWA BY YOUR COUNT?
>> THAT’S GOING TO BE, I
THINK, JUST NEAR THE TOP OF
THE GROUP OF PEOPLE.
WE ARE IN THE TOP FIVE IN
BOTH STATES RIGHT NOW.
AND THAT IS GOOD FOR ME.
BUT I’M DOING MORE THAN
THAT.
WE HAVE DOUBLED OUR STAFF IN
BOTH STATES.
I JUST GOT THE ENDORSEMENT
TODAY OF THE IOWA CITY
NEWSPAPER AS WELL AS THE SEA
COAST IN NEW HAMPSHIRE
ADDING TO THE UNION LEADER
IN NEW HAMPSHIRE AS WELL AS
THE KEEN PAPER AND THE QUAD
CITY’S "NEW YORK TIMES."
ALL OF THEM MAKE THAT CASE
FOR ME THAT I’M SOMEONE THAT
CAN BRING OUR PARTY TOGETHER
AND BRING PEOPLE WITH ME.
AND I THINK THAT’S VERY,
VERY IMPORTANT.
AND I HAVE JUST GOT TO
BELIEVE THAT DESPITE THE
FACT THAT THREE DAYS BEFORE
THE IOWA CAUCUS I NEVER
THOUGHT I WOULD BE HERE IN
THE CAPITOL.
I THOUGHT I WOULD BE OUT
WITH MY COMPETITORS DOING MY
JOB.
I JUST DON’T THINK THAT
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO HOLD
THAT AGAINST ME.
I THINK MY EXPERIENCE
PASSING OVER 100 BILLS BY
WORKING ACROSS THE AISLE
MORE THAN ANYONE IN THE
SENATE, RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT, I THINK THAT’S
GOING TO MATTER.
>> Bret: I JUST HAVE A
MINUTE LEFT.
YOU MENTIONED THE DEBATES
THERE WAS A RULING BY THE
DNC THAT SEEMS TO OPEN THE
DOOR TO MIKE BLOOMBERG
QUALIFYING FOR AT LEAST ONE
DEBATE COMING UP.
ARE YOU OKAY WITH THAT?
>> YES.
I THINK THAT WHEN YOU HAVE
GOT SOMEONE THAT IS RUNNING
ALL THOSE ADS ALL OVER THE
PLACE, INCLUDING A SUPER
BOWL AD, I THINK THAT IT IS
BETTER TO HAVE THAT PERSON
DEBATE IN THE CASE OF MAYOR
BLOOMBERG THAN OUTSIDE JUST
SPENDING A TON OF MONEY.
BECAUSE I WANT TO MAKE THE
CASE TO AMERICA THAT I WOULD
BE THE BEST ONE TO LEAD THE
TICKET.
AND I WOULD RATHER DEBATE
HIM THAN HAVE HIM OUTDO ME
ON THE AIRWAYS.
>> Bret: WHAT HAPPENS IF
BERNIE SANDERS WINS IOWA AND
GOES ON TO WIN NEW
HAMPSHIRE?
WHAT HAPPENS TO THE PARTY?
>> I WOULD SAY THAT THIS IS
A LONG, PRIMARY AND THERE
ARE MANY STEPS ALONG THE
WAY.
I CONTINUE TO BELIEVE THAT
IT IS BEST TO HAVE SOMEONE
LEADING OUR TICKET THAT, FOR
INSTANCE, IN MY CASE, I
DON’T SUPPORT MEDICARE FOR
ALL.
I READ THE BILL.
I NEVER GOT ON IT.
I’M KNOT GOING TO KICK
149 MILLION AMERICANS OFF
THEIR CURRENT HEALTH
INSURANCE WHICH IS WHAT THAT
BILL SAYS ON PAGE 8.
I BELIEVE WITH EDUCATION I
KNOW THAT FREE COLLEGE FOR
ALL SOUNDS GOOD ON A BUMPER
STICKER.
I THINK THE BEST THING IS TO
MATCH OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM
WITH OUR ECONOMY.
AND WHEN YOU DO THAT, YOU
SEE WE HAVE OVER A MILLION
OPENINGS FOR HEALTHCARE
WORKERS, ELECTRICIANS, WE
ARE NOT GOING TO HAVE A
SPORTS MARKETING DEGREES.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A
SHORTAGE OF PLUMBERS.
THIS MEANS INVESTMENT IN K
THROUGH 12.
ONE AND TWO YEAR DEGREES AND
THEN DOUBLING THE PELL
GRANTS FOR COLLEGE STUDENTS.
I THINK THOSE ARE PLANS AND
NOT PIPE DREAMS.
THEY ARE PROGRESSIVE BUT
THEY ARE PRACTICAL.
>> Bret: SENATOR KLOBUCHAR,
WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
I’M HEADING TO IOWA
TOMORROW.
>> OKAY.
>> Bret: WE WILL SEE WHEN
YOU GET.
>> THERE YOU MAY BEAT ME
THERE BUT I’M PLANNING ON